hey guys went back to new rockstars I'm
Sam bachelor gay it is infinity week
we're one week out of the release of a
vendor's infinity war and boy oh boy I'm
excited it's been ten years since the
birth of the MCU and oh boy it's the
beginning of the end according to all
the ads so let's get ready but before
this movie comes out let's recap all the
information and see where all our heroes
and villains are at currently on earth
or in the cosmos heck I'll even mention
the Infinity stones why not I'm feelin
generous today let's get going spoiler
warning for the MCU films the comics may
be infinity war if I happened to get
lucky with my guesses I can't be blamed
for that so let's work our way backwards
the most recent chapter the MCU
chronicled the adventures of King
T'Challa of Wakanda the Black Panther
has decided to open the gates to Wakanda
to share their knowledge and technology
with the queer old with that where
Condon outreach centers have been opened
all around the world in naki and Cherie
have been taking point on sharing
everything Wakanda has to offer
hopefully we can see one of these
centers in infinity war but there's a
lot going on I get that if that doesn't
happen in this movie as for a Quay and
mbaku they're currently protecting and
leading their people but we do see them
in the promotional material for infinity
war so I'm psyched
next Thor Hulk Valkyrie Loki in the rest
days guardians where are they at well
after the destruction of Asgard and the
death of hella they got his death the
entire civilization has left for the
star sitting sights to earth to rebuild
a has garnered the best of their ability
the freed fighters of Sekar also along
for the ride specifically Korg and meek
but there are a few more as well however
the last tease we got during Thor
Ragnarok post-credits scene leads me to
believe that one of Thanos his first
stops on his mission to claim the rest
of the Infinity stones is the Asgardian
rescue ship why you may ask
cuz one slippery brother of Thor Ek Loki
can't keep his dang hands off the
tesseract if you didn't know that's what
houses the space stone lets people
teleport from point A to point B it's
very cool honestly that as guardians are
probably not gonna do so well against
Thanos so I don't mean to be a negative
Nancy but hey that's probably what's
gonna happen also Thorian got me linear
no more it got smushed but maybe that'll
change infinity war I'm getting ahead of
myself next the webhead himself
spider-man after successfully taking
down the vulture Peter was able to get
his high-tech suit back from Tony Stark
not the iron spider suit costume just
yet but is a good one we know
that Peter is in possession of zero
Infinity stones but hey he is fighting
the good fight for the little guy on the
streets of New York moving backwards
once again to our guardians of the
galaxy after their little patricide
adventure or planet toss I'd had to look
that Latin word up planet either way ego
the Living Planet is no more and after a
touching funeral for yondu of the
Ravagers the guardians the galaxies are
off to protect us our team currently
consists of Peter quill aka star-lord
Gamora Drax rocket Groot and mantis we
also had crag Lin roaming around the
ship with all of them but we really
haven't seen him in the promotional
material for infinity war so maybe he's
on a vacation hopefully he's been
through a lot
currently they are in the position of
zero Infinity stones as well but they
did drop off the Power Stone ons and are
the headquarters for the Nova Corps they
also allowed nebula daughter of Thanos
and sister to Gamora to roam free
throughout the galaxy wonder how she'll
pop up in infinity war she's probably
gonna be mash you don't like her dad be
back in time once again wink wink
let's check in with the soon-to-be
sorcerer supreme dr. Stephen strange
that the last time we saw him was
actually in Thor Ragnarok helping the
sons of Odin find their father on earth
but prior to that he was busy learning
the ways of sorcery and saving the earth
from Kai Caecilius now that was my final
breakdown on this channel for the MCU
which you guys should all check out just
sayin now Strange and Wong seem to be
keeping the sanctum sanctorum in New
York safe while also protecting earth
from magical threats along with the
other sorcerers they also know the
whereabouts of another infinity stone at
the time stone which is nestled inside
of the eye of agamotto and finally guys
let's talk about our main Avengers guys
Tony and cap had a bit of a spat there's
a whole movie about it and now have gone
their separate ways team Iron Man and
which consists of currently Tony Vision
Black Widow and Rhodey ache a war
machine our bakit avengers headquarters
in upstate New York trying to keep the
planet safe while cap screw which
includes Falcon Hawkeye ant-man and
Scarlet Witch are on the run that's what
we were left with at the end of civil
war but I do have some updates for that
like how cap has dropped the mantle of
Captain America and he's sort of a nomad
right now see it's a little joke cuz
Steve Rogers becomes the character Nomad
at one point in the comics after
dropping the mantle of Captain America
and it looks like he's becoming nomad in
the MCU because it's costumes all black
now you
just as the black costume and usually
different shield and sometimes the cape
also Bucky had his arm blown off by Iron
Man is currently recovering in Wakanda
and we did see him in one of the
post-credits scenes for Black Panther
and he seems to be doing a o.k hopefully
he gets a kick-ass new arm however based
on the teasers and trailers for infinity
war things have changed for these two
teams now as far as we know vision has
snuck off with Scarlet Witch and there's
somewhere smoochin and doing their
lovey-dovey thing however one would do
that with a synthetic person not to
judge those two are also busy trying to
keep the mine Stone envisions head safe
from prying eyes as for the rest of team
cap Black Widow has joined their ranks
and they're most likely on the run
around the world helping people where
they can how they can
as for Ant Man and Hawk guy that's tough
to say based on the trailers for ant-man
on the wasp II could quite possibly beat
on house arrest over in San Francisco
but Hawkeye well you should just check
out Eric's Theory video he just put out
I texted him my personal theory and he
added it to the video I was very
flattered and I hope it does come true
but there you have it that's where all
of our heroes are currently in the MCU
some in space some in hiding some swing
around in Queens
currently Thanos in his Black Order are
probably scheming to go find them stones
in his sanctuary but they're on their
way and we should all be afraid our
characters are not safe right now also
also just in case you were wondering v
stone that we already know about the
ether aka the reality stone is currently
locked away in the collectors collection
on nowhere now not to be a jury do you
but that probably isn't a great place to
hide an infinity stone but hey now
here's a question for you guys how do
you think Hawkeye is going to stop they
a knows yes it's probably gonna come all
down to him right I mean he's not there
must be the secret weapon let's get
creative kids don't just say he's gonna
arrow I'm in the eye but that's just my
theory guys I'm at Sam basher on Twitter
send me your theories or hit up the
comments section down below but also
like this video and share it with your
friends and also tune in later this week
for more infinity week videos they're
gonna be awesome
I'm Sam basher once again check out my
box only stupid answers to talk about
nerdy things over there and I'll see you
guys next time